bien je suis très heureux
d'accueillir avec vous le professeur
Jean garrigue
il ne pouvait pas y avoir d'hommes mieux
adapté pour traiter le sujet que nous
traitons
et spécialement pour traiter le sujet
que nous traitons ici
Jean garrigue est un historien éminent
il enseigne l'histoire
contemporaine à l'université si je dis
une bêtise vous me dites à l'université
d'Orléans
il est le président le responsable du
centre
du Comité d'études historique et
politique c'est ça historique politique
d'histoire parlementaire et politique de
paix
il est spécialiste de l'histoire il a
deux sujets de préoccupation
intellectuelle enfin qui organise ses
études
la première c'est l'histoire des centres
et la deuxième c'est l'histoire des
rapports entre le monde économique et le
monde politique et donc ces deux sujets
là le rendait bien sûr
tout désigné
pour cette réflexion sur précisément
la République
face
aux tentatives et aux tentations de
corruption
cette je veux ajouter cela à votre usage
et à l'usage de ce beaucoup plus
nombreux qui ne regarde sur internet
comme vous y êtes maintenant habitué
c'est un homme pour qui j'ai une grande
estime intellectuelle et Jean-Pierre
Riou va vous le présenter plus avant
parce que
lui aussi partage avec
Jean garrigue les centres d'intérêt que
vous savez de l'histoire
intellectuelle des courants politiques
qui nous intéresse dans la République
mais je tiens à dire moi qui est assez
souvent débattu avec lui ou parler avec
lui par exemple dans le cadre des
Journées de l'histoire de Blois dont il
est un des responsables ou un des
animateurs que c'est un homme d'une
qualité tout à fait imminente qui le
désirent dans un premier temps pour
parler devant vous et comme le temps est
long et que je lui ai dit plus souvent
je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui devra
dans la cité
défendre les idées qu'il aura longuement
élaboré au travers des travaux
universitaires qui ont été les siens
donc je vais maintenant passer la parole
à Jean-Pierre Riou pour une introduction
adaptée
oui
merci agent Gary d'être avec nous ce
soir donc François l'a dit une épreuve
série université d'Orléans dans nos
grands spécialistes d'histoire politique
et parlementaires
et puis le titre de ces de ces travaux
au fil des années montre bien que il est
un des deux ceux qui sont le plus
capables de traiter le sujet de ce soir
il a fait un livre sur le général
Boulanger il n'est pas il a fait un
livre sur la République des affaires des
hommes d'affaires il a fait un livre sur
les scandales de la République et il a
fait quelque chose doit prévoir une
suite mais c'est sans doute prévue
n'est-ce pas pour l'édition de poche
n'est-ce pas à tout d'usage et
il a dirigé un livre qui peut vous être
à tous très utile il a dirigé
80 collègues et amis dont moi sur la
France de la 5ème République est une
très bonne mise au point sur quantité de
sujets et Jean a signé notamment une
exécrable François beiraud dans cette
ouvrage collectif moi je me suis
contenté de faire autre chose prudent
voilà bon donc tout ça pour vous dire la
qualité de l'ami qui veut bien nous
rejoindre ce soir alors sur un sujet bon
plus que d'actualité quand même on a eu
un week-end pas triste quand même entre
le sourire de Monsieur Cahuzac sur le
marché de Villeneuve-sur-Lot c'est quand
même quelque chose et le non-lieu de
Monsieur wurt bon voilà où le bon lieu
prochain
bon alors nous examinons je vais être
très bref pour compléter je vous signale
que Jean a fait une très bonne interview
dans réforme le 11 avril 2013 vous
retrouverez peut-être ça assez
facilement ou j'espère qu'il va nous en
dire à peu près l'essentiel ce soir bah
nous examinons ce que certains appellent
les zones grises de la démocratie ou la
zone grise de la démocratie
parce que quoi que nous disions et que
nous pensions c'est intimement lié à la
démocratie cette affaire et donc tout ce
qui touche aux arrangements aux
favoritisme au conflit d'intérêts etc
etc au dessous de table et au paradis
fiscaux
est assez intimement lié et donc ce qui
voudrait peut-être aller loin plus loin
je vous signale le petit livre de Pierre
lascum qui s'appelle une démocratie
corruptible dans la collection La
République des idées c'est un livre de
sciences politiques pas très facile pas
tout à fait pas très vivant pas facile
d'abord mais qui
explique comment la science politique
ici est là et pas seulement en France à
analyser ces phénomènes de de corruption
donc je vais laisser la parole à Jean
garrigue et avec quand même en tête de
deux choses qui nous préoccupent tous
politiquement puisque beaucoup d'entre
vous doivent être doivent être en train
de de réfléchir à des listes pour les
municipales avec quelles alliances et
qu'elle et qu'elle favoris et qu'elle
implantation je dirais dans les mini ou
les grands éventuels scandale locaux bon
que comment gérer ça politiquement au
nom de cette clarté cette honnêteté que
nous revendiquons tous et à tout moment
dès lors qu'on est quand même dans une
logique qui consiste à dire tous pourris
bien sûr tous pourris mais si on dit
tous pourris on ne peut jamais désigner
les vrais pourris c'est ça la grande
difficulté je crois politique bon et
donc le tout dans vous le savez mieux
que moi dans le rôle accélérer des
médias et je dirais la l'activisme
politique qui fait que la réponse
aujourd'hui en France notamment
l'affaire Cahuzac a été dit a été soyons
transparentes tout de suite et à jamais
et dans dans les circonstances que vous
savez donc je n'en dis pas plus j'en tu
as la parole
merci merci beaucoup je suis évidemment
très heureux d'être parmi vous c'est la
deuxième fois d'ailleurs que je que je
viens l'invitation de de Jean-Pierre et
de François Bayrou
je les remercie pour leur compliment qui
sont bien trop bien trop élogieux sur
mon sens politique j'ai quelques
réticences sinon je ne serai pas encore
professeur à l'Université d'Orléans
réussi à me faire élire à Paris
donc voilà j'ai quelques réserves sur
mes propres capacités en revanche ce qui
est vrai c'est que depuis un certain
temps je suis au fond un des rares
historiens et politistes à m'intéresser
à ces questions du rapport entre les
hommes de pouvoir et l'argent qui me
paraissent pourtant des questions
fondamentales et dont je sais que
François Bayrou a fait un de ses champs
de réflexion et au fond là aussi sur le
long terme on s'aperçoit qu'il est
relativement isolé dans la classe
politique et pour avoir une pensée
cohérente sur ces sur ces questions
alors évidemment les affaires qui
viennent de se produire mais comme vous
le disiez je pourrais rajouter à
delimiteum des chapitres à mon histoire
des scandales c'est l'affaire récente
touche à la dissimulation de Frost
fiscale pour Monsieur Cahuzac au
soupçons de financement occulte des
partis politiques en ce qui concerne la
ferveur de Sarkozy la faire Guéno
Sarkozy comme on faut-il l'appeler voir
la faire géant conduit dans ces dans ces
zones troubles et elle pose la question
elle pose plusieurs questions elle pose
la question du mensonge public donc
d'une culture de l'opacité sur laquelle
je vais revenir et qui me semble être
une vieille tradition française elle
pose la question du rôle des
contre-pouvoirs et on a vu à travers ce
qui était l'action notamment de d'un
média qui s'appelle Mediapart ce que
pouvait être le questionnement sur ce
des contre-pouvoirs elle pose la
question si des vertus thérapeutiques du
scandale à travers les décisions prises
à chaud par François Hollande pour
prendre les conséquences de ces de ces
affaires ou de ces scandales et elle
pose aussi la question de l'exploitation
comme d'habitude de ces de ces affaires
le thème du coup de balai qui de façon
assez surprenante d'ailleurs n'est pas
venue cette fois de l'extrême droite
comme c'est la règle mais de l'extrême
gauche de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce qui pose
aussi la question des la diversité des
populismes et de la difficulté aller
qualifier mais ça ce sera encore un
autre problème alors ces questions là
évidemment sont des questions que je me
suis déjà posées dans en travaillant sur
l'histoire des scandales histoire des
affaires et ce sont des questions qui
s'opposent évidemment aux universitaires
comme moi comme aux politiques je vais
les traiter quatre ou cinq points en
essayant de pas être trop long ne pas
vous abreuver sous des un des des récits
historiques et en vous conseillant de
lire cette histoire des scandales qui a
été rééditée en poche aux éditions du
Nouveau Monde et puis en relisant en
lisant aussi les œuvres de Pierre
Lascaux même qui j'ai souvent débattu et
travailler
qu'un nom du Sud-Ouest mais enfin c'est
aussi donc je suis fier et
cette cette
cette question là d'abord c'est un
problème éternel de la démocratie
quelque chose de nouveau et de cantonné
à la Cinquième République ou aux années
qui viennent de s'écouler déjà sous la
République romaine 70 ans avant notre
ère un puissant magistrat de la cité
romaine qui s'appelait veres avait été
accusé de détournement de fond d'abus de
pouvoir une pratique à l'époque n'était
pas exceptionnelle mais il avait trouvé
sur sa route un accusateur public de
grand talents sortent dans cette de
mélange d'édouis pleinel et d'éval joli
qui s'appelait Cicéron
avec le talent oratoire de François
Bayrou par exemple et
qui avait obligé VRS a quitté la cité de
Rome il s'était réfugié à Marseille où
il avait d'ailleurs coulé des jours très
heureux comme la plupart des des hommes
politiques qui ont à faire à la justice
aujourd'hui mais déjà
le scandale de corruption était un
composante de la vie politique puisque
essentiellement pour Cicéron l'objectif
de son accusation n'était pas tellement
de discrédité vérince mais de
discréditer autour d'overesse qu'on
appelle partie des aristocrate en fait
alors que lui était représentant du
parti des populaires vous voyez de
quelle manière le la question du rapport
à l'argent est aussi une composante un
moteur à catalyseur de de la vie
politique et au fond c'est ce qui
m'intéresse aussi dans ces scandales le
scandale fait partie de la vie politique
d'ailleurs pas seulement sous la
démocratie simplement dans les régimes
autoritaires on en parle pas et les
dérives les détournements de fond etc
les corruption c'est beaucoup plus
facile dans ces régimes nos autoritaires
ça a toujours existé dans les régimes de
monarchie française qu'elles soient
royaliste ou impérial le Second Empire
était friand de ce genre de de dérive
mais c'est vrai qu'avec la démocratie
vous vous avez la séparation des
pouvoirs la compétition entre les
parties la liberté de la presse aussi et
donc à la fois des occasions multiples
de corrompre et des occasions multiples
d'utiliser la corruption comme une arme
politique et c'est pourquoi la cette
arme-là est devenue redoutable et c'est
pourquoi l'évolution au fond de nos
républiques depuis
1870 depuis que la démocratie
parlementaire s'est définitivement
installé en France peu apparaître comme
une sorte de litanie de scandale j'en
avais comptabilisé une bonne quarantaine
voire une cinquantaine dans les 150 ans
qui que j'avais étudié alors bon
plusieurs remarques à cet égard et là
encore je voudrais essayer que ma
réflexion historique ne soit pas trop
lourde et qu'elle nous amène à des
réflexions plus présentes c'est sans
doute essentiellement ce que vous
attendez de mon intervention mais pardon
je vais être obligé aussi de faire
référence au passé
qui m'intéresse d'abord un constat qui
se dégage c'est que les conjonctures de
crise comme celles que nous vivons crise
profonde qui va bien au-delà d'une crise
conjoncturelle né des subprimes en 2008
qui est une crise de profonde de
mutation de la société française depuis
40 ans cette ces périodes de crise sont
le terreau privilégié de ses affaires ce
sont des moments privilégiés pour
qu’éclatent ses affaires les grands
scandales des années 1880 se faisait sur
fond d'une crise économique mondiale
comment ça en 1882 les salles des années
30 pareil les les grandes périodes de de
scandale les grandes périodes d'affaires
sont des périodes qui sont liées à une
instabilité politique morale sociale de
des sociétés démocratiques et finalement
on peut constater que les grandes les
grandes glorieuses de l'économie
française ces années 45 75 70 ont été
relativement exemptes de ce type
d'affaires il y en a eu j'y reviendrai
mais au fond on voit bien qu'il y a une
relation de cause à effet et que les
affaires se sont multipliées depuis que
la société française est en crise alors
il y a d'autres raisons je vais revenir
mais c'est aussi c'est un premier point
qu'il faut qu'il faut souligner et qui
a permis évidemment à tous les partis on
peut qualifier rapidement de populistes
extrémiste simplificateur à la recherche
de bouc émissaires évidemment de
prospérer sur ce terreau du scandale en
période de crise la droite nationaliste
avait exploité boulangisme avait
exploité l'affaire des décorations en
1897 la droite nationaliste était en
pointe dans la dénonciation de du
scandale de Panama en 1892 pareil au
moment de la faire Stavisky en 1934 les
poujadistes ce sont intéressés ou
scandale des années 50 et les
communistes aussi beaucoup dans les
années 50 et puis on sait que le Front
national c'est nourri c'est la brevet
depuis les années 1880 de ses dérives de
la de la démocratie avec aujourd'hui
peut-être une dimension supplémentaire
dans cette conjoncture qui est la nôtre
et qui est qui a très sans doute au
symbolique qui ont été générés par la
présidence de Nicolas Sarkozy autour du
président des riches à cette
frénésie au fond de d'une droite
décomplexée par rapport à l'argent qui
était une des grandes idées de Nicolas
Sarkozy et qui finalement a abouti à
quoi à faire poser une suspicion
généralisée sur la classe politique dans
son rapport soi-disant privilégié à
l'argent et qui entraîne une intolérance
et une moindre capacité de d'acceptation
de l'opinion publique vis-à-vis de ces
de ces dérives je crois que ça c'est
quelque chose
conjoncturellement qui est intéressant à
étudier je pense que ce qui s'est passé
sous la présidence de Nicolas Sarkozy a
entraîné là encore une dramatisation de
de cette
positionnement de l'opinion vis-à-vis de
ses problèmes
troisième point le troisième point c'est
de dire que évidemment il y a une
évolution historique de ces de ce
rapport à l'argent et de ce qui fait
scandale par rapport à à l'argent là on
peut dire que au fond on est allé des de
la dénonciation des comportements
individuels vers je dirais des systèmes
vers des dénonciations si de nature
systémique et je m'explique la Troisième
République
incontestablement c'est l'époque où
commence à découvrir la corruption
individuelle corruption de d'un Daniel
Wilson président gendre du président de
la République et qui vous le savez
depuis l'Élysée trafic industriellement
des décorations notamment des lésions
d'honneur et s'enrichit considérablement
il n'avait pas besoin d'ailleurs parce
qu'il était déjà très riche industriel
corruption des individus parlementaires
même si ça touche sans 150 députés
sénateurs moments du scandale de Panama
c'est une corruption de masse mais qui
intéresse individuellement qu'on
assimile pas à un système je vais
revenir alors qu'en réalité il
s'agissait d'une sorte de système de
dons et de contredons qui s'était
installés dans la vie politique de la
Troisième République et puis ça mène
jusqu'au ripoux de la Troisième
République comme des escrocs comme
Rochette ou strict qui travaille
magouille avec quelques hommes
politiques ici elle a des avocats
d'affaires particulièrement et puis les
ripoux de la cinquième des féodaux
municipaux comme Jacques Médecin à Nice
Michel Mouillot
Maurice sareks à Toulon Jean-Michel
Boucheron à Angoulême qui sont un peu la
finalement la queue de comète de ces
phénomènes de corruption individuelle
qui finalement ont tenu en haleine les
médias la presse pendant toutes ces
périodes avec effectivement une sorte de
de religion républicaine qui s'agrippent
assez à ses dérives de l'argent
et qui au fond est la conséquence d'un
d'une sorte de double héritage
historique qui fusionne à la fois la
diabolisation de l'argent
entretenue pendant des siècles par
l'Église catholique
romaine mais aussi par la gauche
française
à partir très tôt à partir de de la
période robespierreiste on va dire et
puis la soif d'intégrité de la tradition
républicaine de sorte que la religion
républicaine est le respect d'une
éthique citoyenne qui veut que l'élu
soit imperméable à l'argent et la
corruption est apparaît comme le péché
capital de cette de ces dérives
républicaines j'y ajouterai ensuite la
ferisme la ferrims qui souvent se
rapproche gravement de la corruption qui
ne se confond pas avec la corruption
mais qui est très souvent lisière de la
corruption le goût de l'argent le
mélange des intérêts évidemment il y a
une infinité de gradation dans cette
dans cette affairisme qui apparaît
scandaleux un Joseph caillou par exemple
au début du 20e siècle
flirt avec le scandale parce qu'il est
considéré comme un homme politique à
ferriste
Jean de Broye à l'époque de
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing des proches de
Valéry Giscard d'est un proche au début
moi ensuite est un homme qui traîne avec
lui un parfum assez sulfureux on
pourrait en parler de cette affaire de
Breuil qu'il a conduit d'ailleurs à la
mort mais qui voilà ça n'est pas de la
corruption mais c'est un lien trouble
avec c'est une zone trouble avec le
monde des affaires
je le répète on est là aux frontières de
de l'abus bien sociale du clientélisme
de la complaisance aussi envers les
intérêts privés et là par exemple une
affaire comme celle de ce qu'on appelle
l'affaire Aranda en 1972 lorsque ce haut
fonctionnaire du ministère de
l'Équipement
dévoile un certain nombre de dossiers de
l'aide de correspondance qui montre à
quel point les élus Gaulistes finalement
entraîne vraiment très largement avec
l'intérêt de l'État et favorise leurs
clientèle politique leurs clientèle
électorales et leurs privé avec des
intérêts industriels je dirais que ça
mène jusqu'au délit d'initié de la
période de la dose du deuxième septennat
de François Mitterrand les délais
d'initiés à propos de l'affaire
péchinelle à faire la Société Générale
le rôle des chefs de cabinet du ministre
de l'Économie des Finances de l'époque
homme intègre Pierre Bérégovoy mais le
rôle de son entourage les hommes comme
Jean-Charles naori Alain Boublil pose
quand même la question de cette
affairisme cette gangrène à ferriste
cette confusion des genres qui pèse sur
la vie politique parfois il s'agit tout
simplement d'un prudence de légèreté si
on prend le cas par exemple Robert
Boulin Robert Boulin
là aussi des scénar dans les
circonstances tragiques en 1979 à la
suite
d'une affaire un petit peu trouble dans
laquelle il a pu se montrer assez léger
vis-à-vis des intérêts privés tel Roland
Dumas acceptant les cadeaux de
Christine de Dijon cours Dominique
Strauss-Kahn dissimulant ou cachant ou
oubliant la cassette de Jean-Claude Méry
dans sa boîte à gants où Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing acceptant les cadeaux de de
les trophées de chasse de son cousin
Bokassa l'appartement de d'ervé Guemar
les cigares de Christian Blanc tout ça
ce n'est plus de la ferrisme c'est une
conception au fond et c'est très
important pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé depuis la Troisième République
dans la la classe politique française la
caste politique française c'est
conception régalienne du pouvoir qui
fait qu'en réalité prendre quelques
libertés avec la règle avec avec la
norme avec l'éthique c'est pas bien
grave parce qu'au fond on est
propriétaire de son pouvoir on est
propriétaire du pouvoir politique et
finalement la transparence le devoir
d'intégrité finalement passe au second
plan vis-à-vis de cette propriété du
pouvoir d'ailleurs que dire des
trésoriers des partis politiques
impliqués dans les années 90 et pas
seulement d'ailleurs le Parti socialiste
toutes les familles politiques
malheureusement impliqués dans des
systèmes plus illégaux que les uns que
les autres pour courir après les
dépenses exorbitantes et là aussi il y
aurait peut-être une réflexion à mener
de campagne
ça me mène à ce que j'appelle les
dérives systémiques c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a une autre chronologie de la des
affaires une autre chronologie de la
corruption qui qui nous montre que des
systèmes se sont mis en place je parlais
tout à l'heure de Panama vous avez 150
député sénateurs qui dans les années
1890 son prix la main dans le sac la
main dans le pot de confiture pour avoir
accepté des peaux de vin de la compagnie
de Panama la presse est totalement
corrompue d'ailleurs aussi dans cette
affaire il y a un système il y a un
système qui fait que pour ces hommes
politiques là à la fin du 19e siècle
recevoir des petits cadeaux de la part
de chef d'entreprise de la part de
société privée d'hommes d'affaires des
tuyaux boursiers etc relève de la
normalité du don et du contredo il y a
un système radical dans les années 30
qui fait que Stavisky l'escroc est
protégé par des avocats d'affaires qui
travaillent pour lui éventuellement par
un procureur éventuellement un président
du conseil il y en a beaucoup parlé de
de Camille autant à l'époque au fond par
le Parti radical dans son ensemble qui
ferme les yeux sur ses liens complices
avec
Stavisky il y a un système colonial sur
lequel on pourrait revenir mais je vais
pas m'étendre il y a un système
gaulliste à l'état gaulisme des années
60 notamment dans ses liens avec le
monde de la promotion immobilière et qui
aboutit à une litanie de scandale
immobilier sur la garantie foncière
notamment en 1971 qui qui implique un
député André Riva Henri qui était un
proche de Jacques Chaban-Delmas qui a ce
qui a contribué beaucoup à faffaiblir
Jacques chavanelmas et bien tout ça
relève là aussi d'une dérive systémique
ce qui fait dire à Michel Poniatowski à
l'époque qu'il y a les copains et les
coquins de l'État gaulliste ce qui fait
que Georges Marchais va conduire des
manifestations au cri de Chaban
d'émissions un régime des scandales
alors que chavanelma très
vraisemblablement assez loin de cette de
ces dérives à faireistes et encore
certains journalistes que j'ai consultés
me disent que bon
il y a le système giscardien
autour de Jean de Breuil on a beaucoup
parlé au moment de son de son assassinat
on a parlé de financement plus ou moins
occultes des Républicains indépendants
dont il était le trésorier bon me
prononce pas ce n'est pas mon rôle le
système mitterrandien le système
mitterrandien alors que la cinquantième
des 110 propositions de François
Mitterrand 110 proposition il avait eu
cette habitude pas parler de programme
la justice sera appelée à faire toute la
lumière sur les affaires dans lesquelles
ont été mises en cause des personnes
publiques quel paradoxe si on évalue par
la suite ce qu'on était les deux
présidents de François Mitterrand
comment se mythe de l'intégrité a
totalement explosé en vol au vu des
pratiques alors pourquoi cette explosion
des affaires sous à l'époque
mitterrandis pourquoi ce système
mitterrandien bien parce que le contexte
des années 86 prête c'est l'apologie de
l'argent roi ce qu'on appelait les
années frites les années des golden boys
d'où le danger des cultures de l'argent
quand elles se propage de manière trop
vous voyez trop active trop trop
prégnant dans une société
c'est l'époque de aussi l'avènement de
la politique spectacle et le déferlement
des besoins sans cesse plus importants
des parties et des candidats d'où le
danger aussi de ses dérives me
semble-t-il mais là il faudrait que les
politiques notamment François Bayrou
donne son avis les plus qualifié que moi
pour pour le pour le donner de l'argent
toujours de l'argent il faut bien le
trouver déclare Gérard Monate qui était
l'homme du système
urbain système de bureau d'études
extrêmement régulés
franchisé c'était mis en place pour
drainer de l'argent vers les candidats
le socialistes c'est ce qu'il dit le 6
octobre 1989 au moment où l'affaire a
déjà éclaté et puis toutes ces lois sur
la décentralisation qui ont donné de
nouveaux pouvoirs collectivités locales
collectivités régionales et évidemment
on favorisait la multiplication des
appétits donc des occasions de corrompre
et toutes ces féodalités locales qui
sont qui ont émergées comme ça dans les
années
19990 que ça soit sur des individus ou
des systèmes comme par exemple le
système des vous savez les attributions
des des marchés des lycées
d'Île-de-France autour du président du
conseil régional Michel Giraud avec une
distribution extrêmement là aussi
régulée entre les grands partis
politiques
ont presque tous les grands partis il
faut le reconnaître une famille était
restée perméable une autre aussi mais
bon nous intéressement
c'était resté imperméable ce type de de
répartition malsaine bon
tout ce choc de ce choc de l'opinion
face au délits d'initier donc dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure Société Générale et
péchiné en 1988 et qui permet à Alain
Juppé j'allais dire presque légitimement
de dénoncer la gauche la plus pourrie du
monde
c'est surtout la fin d'une illusion
celle de cette gauche morale et
incorruptible qui au fond c'était
toujours présenté jusqu'aux années 80
quand une sorte de rempart face à cette
république corruptive qui fait l'objet
de nos réflexions aujourd'hui et puis et
puis il y a aussi et alors à contrario
le réveil des contre-pouvoirs qui est
une chose très importante au tournant
des années 80 la presse française
s'inspirant du modèle anglo-saxon le
modèle du Watergate on a que le
Watergate à la bouche et apparaît une
génération de journée ce qu'ils veulent
mener des investigations sur ces
problèmes sur ces dérives et ils peuvent
désormais collaborer avec une nouvelle
génération de juge elle est dirigeants
pierre renouveau ring Beck et va jolie
ricalfen bien décidée à rompre le mur du
silence qui avait été imposé jusque là
et qui va l'être encore à certains
moments de notre histoire politique et
avec des nouvelles pratiques la pratique
systématique des fuites bon
l'instruction vers la presse les
perquisitions coup de poing certaines
stérilisations des juges qui évidemment
fait hurler les politiques et on
comprend mais qui en même temps au fond
sont apparus à l'époque comme les
instruments indispensables de cette de
ce réveil des contre-pouvoirs et puis il
y a le système Chirac c'est un Chirac
qui se révèle à la fin des années 90
système de financement cultes du RPR
étroitement liés à la mairie de Paris et
à ses marchés essentiellement marché des
HLM n'est pas seulement et alors là
système avec des fusibles les Michel
roussins Pérols Robert pendro et Alain
Juppé qui vont jouer le rôle de fusible
alors que celui qui est au cœur du
système a priori est aussi au cœur de la
polémique lorsque le monde du 22
septembre 2000 publie le fameux texte de
la cassette vidéo enregistré par
Jean-Claude Méry en
1996 et qui accuse Jacques Chirac
d'avoir été présent lors d'une remise
d'argent
occulte
en octobre 1986 et là ça nous amène à
une quatrième idée qui est cette culture
de l'opacité de l'omerta française qui
est quand même quelque chose de très
très fort puisque face à aux aveux de
celui qui était quand même
l'intermédiaire de alors même s'il avait
des comment dirais-je qu'on pouvait
mettre en doute sa parole et puis et
surtout c'est c'est je dirais ces
arrière-pensées bon il y avait quand
même là matière à réfléchir pour la
classe politique et on se heurte à quoi
on sortait une petite phrase à Brad
cabra d'abrantesque bon on se heurte à
ce que dit Jacques Chirac il n'y a pas
de crise morale et politique en France
aujourd'hui pas de crise morale le 14
décembre 2000 alors que moins de deux
ans plus tard à l'élection
présidentielle Jean-Marie Le Pen est au
deuxième tour on croit rêver ou en tout
cas on est là quand même dans un déni de
réalité
déni d'ailleurs encouragé par
l'opposition de gauche puisque elle est
elle-même engluée dans ses propres
affaires la nef pour Dominique je
Strauss-Kahn les affaires qui tournent
autour d'elfe pour Roland Dumas
président du Conseil constitutionnel
celui-là même qui va valider l'immunité
du président de la République Jacques
Chirac et l'on voit bien à quel point ça
c'est de tout éternité cette espèce de
jeu de tu me tiens par la barbichette
entre là de au fond de d'impunité
croisée et bien contribue à cette
impunité à cette opacité du monde
politique et alors ça conduit à quoi ben
ça conduit à une sorte de mouvement de
je dirais d'attaque ranger contre les
contre-pouvoirs c'est-à-dire ne riposte
des politiques contre la presse et la
justice François Mitterrand janvier 1992
la presse prend les hommes politiques
pour des ennemis c'est comme ça que la
démocratie s'est altérée lui qui avait
fait campagne en 1980 précisément pour
la la transparence la la régulation le
contrôle est la lentille corruption et
c'est ce qu'avait d'ailleurs répété
Pierre Bérégovoy lorsqu'il avait fait
son discours d'investiture sur de
politique générale pardon en 1992
c'est là que Pierre François Mitterrand
la mort de Pierre Bérégovoy parlera des
chiens qui ont aboyé
faisait allusion à certains médias et
notamment
cette cette comment dirais cette
constance dans la volonté
d'immunité d'entretenir l'immunité des
politiques l'explique aussi la levée de
boucliers contre média parte au moment
de la faire Cahuzac et on s'aperçoit
après coup que peut-être et bien on
aurait dû être un peu plus à l'écoute de
ce que disait un média même si ce média
peut être critiqué les outrances les
partis pris de celui qui le dirige
peuvent être sujets à critiques et je
j'y souscris moi aussi on voit ce qui
est advenu aussi des juges de ces de
cette génération des juges des années 90
dont beaucoup ont dû jeté l'éponge et et
de manière tout à fait caractéristique
s'orienter dans le champ politique pour
pouvoir mener leur combat anticorruption
c'est à dire que une eva jolie un
erikalfène tous les défauts qu'on peut
leur trouver là encore il s'agit pas de
les idéaliser mais enfin il faut
constater quand même que les juges ont
été là aussi très affaiblis par le
pouvoir politique et qu'au fond depuis
que des grandes lois des années 90 sont
réglementés tentés de réglementer le
financement occulte des partis
politiques c'est loin été régulièrement
contournés contournés par des
associations de complaisance par des
salaires fictifs par des paradis fiscaux
l'affaire Cly stream l'affaire clear
stream c'était aussi une affaire de
paradis fiscaux c'était avant tout une
affaire de paradis fiscaux avant d'être
un règlement de compte politique entre
Nicolas Sarkozy et Dominique de Villepin
alors évidemment tout ça je vais essayer
de pas trop être trop long je dis
toujours ça et puis et puis je me perds
dans les détails mais tout cela
entretient évidemment une méfiance
envers les élites politiques et cette
méfiance elle dure depuis le début de la
Troisième République elle a récupérer
par les populismes tous pourris c'est un
thème récurrent
je le dis à ceux qui m'interrogent les
journalistes nous sommes pas dans les
années 30 la société française n'est pas
celle des années 30 la démocratie
duomercice aussi quelque chose qui est
l'objet d'une maturation donc les gens
comprennent et le tout pourri n'a pas la
même valeur aujourd'hui qu'elle l'avait
qu'il l'avait à l'époque il n'empêche
que le fossé est là que la méfiance est
là et que particulièrement en ce moment
et bien on est on est dans un regain de
méfiance envers les élites et notamment
envers les élites politiques mais il
faut voir aussi que et ça aussi c'est
une constante historique il y a une
thérapie démocratique c'est-à-dire que
ce que permet la démocratie c'est à dire
c'est dérives et bien elle permet aussi
de l'essayer de les résoudre d'essayer
en tout cas de les mettre à jour et
c'est très important de les mettre à
jour il ne faut pas il ne faut surtout
pas rejeter le la dénonciation des
affaires parce que elle
occasionnent ces dérives populistes non
non il faut les accepter c'est
d'ailleurs les populistes et les prendre
à bras le corps et essayer de résoudre
les problèmes alors moi je vois trois
directions pour résoudre ces problèmes
de la démocratie aujourd'hui du côté de
l'opinion publique il faut il faut
justement passer de cette culture du
cynisme de la résignation à une culture
de l'exigence c'est-à-dire la culture de
l'exigence qu'on peut trouver par
exemple me semble-t-il sans l'idéaliser
là encore dans les modèles scandinaves
en Europe du Nord voir dans certains
certaines institutions qui existent dans
les pays anglo-saxons y compris aux
États-Unis où la vérification de
contrôle sont incontestablement beaucoup
plus forts qui ne le sont dans notre
classe politique française évidemment il
y avait des tas de de
de moyens on pourra on pourra y revenir
mais il y a une société française qui du
bas jusqu'au sommet est trop familiarisé
avec ces pratiques de la déviance du
dysfonctionnement de la dérive de de la
débrouille en quelque sorte ça va du
de ce qu'on appelle le black jusqu'à
jusqu'au dérive de nous élites
politiques il y a dans la société
française une indulgence coupable envers
les fraudeurs et les tricheurs du bas de
l'échelle au sommet de l'ascenseur
social et c'est pas un hasard si les
rapports de transparentie international
nous classe seulement au 22e rang
mondial
parmi les plus mauvais élèves de
l'Europe nous sommes en retard comme sur
beaucoup de points d'ailleurs nous
sommes en retard à l'échelle européenne
et nous sommes dans le peloton de des
mauvais élèves de l'Europe avec des pays
comme la Grèce etc bon
deuxième chose du côté je dirais de
l'appareil politique au judiciaire il
faut passer d'une culture de l'impunité
de cette culture très régalienne de jeux
je suis propriétaire du pouvoir et ce
pouvoir ni toucher pas trop et nous
appartient et l'opinion n'a pas trop à
s'en saisir à une culture de la sanction
il faut aller véritablement à la
sanction des dérives parce que cette
sanction historiquement et bien on la
trouve très rarement et où de manière
très légère
l'affaire de Panama dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure c'est 150 personnes qui
sont dont on a quasiment prouvé la
culpabilité et un seul condamné
Stavisky c'est deux ou trois députés qui
ont des radicaux qui ont été exclus
pendant trois ou quatre ans du Parti
radical c'est pas beaucoup les affaires
de Paris le système le système de la
Mairie de Paris bon voilà principal
responsable passé plus ou moins à côté
de tout ça donc toute quoi mais ça mène
à ce que nous dit Monsieur Henri Guénon
c'est à dire que il remet en cause le
pouvoir judiciaire le rôle de du juge
d'instruction et ça peut mener à des
dérives qui vont beaucoup plus loin je
pourrais développer troisième point du
côté des politiques là encore il faut
passer d'une culture régalienne à une
véritable culture démocratique et je
crois que certains hommes politiques en
sont persuadés ils ont écrit des choses
là-dessus certains qui sont à cette
table d'ailleurs donc je souscris je
souscris il faut absolument que il y ait
une prise de conscience des politiques
j'ai l'impression que c'est le cas dans
les jeunes générations politiques je
pense qu'il y a une prise de conscience
en tout cas tous ceux avec lesquels j'ai
eu l'occasion de parler mais
pas non plus forcément dans la
confidence
parce que la volonté de de
purger les écuries d'ogias la la volonté
de réguler tout ça c'est très très vieux
c'est c'est ça ça remonte aux années
1880 et c'est pas passé grand chose
alors évidemment attention attention
à la transparence qui est une fausse
régulation transparence c'est le
voyeurisme c'est l'américanisation de la
vie politique c'est ce à quoi nous amené
d'ailleurs la présidente Sarkozy et
d'ailleurs au fond la présidente
Hollande et je dirais même le couple
Hollande Royal pendant des années c'est
à dire une sorte de de storytelling
permanent de publicisation de l'intime
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça que que l'on
demande c'est pas qu'on publie les
patrimoines de nos de nos élus parce que
ça au contraire ça contribue à
entretenir la suspicion puisqu'on se dit
ce qu'on nous ce qu'on nous livre là
c'est des broutilles ce n'est pas vrai
non le contrôle le contrôle des
institutions et des moyens pour
contrôler c'est ça dont nous avons
besoin me semble bleu-il attention aussi
à la législation à chaud c'est-à-dire ce
qui s'est passé à ce qui se passe
régulièrement est-ce qu'il s'est passé
avec le rôle et le programme le projet
de François Hollande très étonnant parce
qu'au fond il y a des commissions qui
travaillent depuis très longtemps mais
plusieurs y compris la commission Jospin
bon et là soudain hop on nous sort comme
un comme un lapin de son chapeau des
mesures de de qui relève là encore j'ai
l'impression moi du paraître et non pas
de la réalité de la régulation bref
beaucoup de choses à dire comme le
disait georges Bonnet à la Chambre le 14
novembre 1930 dites-leur que c'en est
fini des scandales de la camarade de la
camaraderie des complaisances coupables
et bien ça c'est ce que j'adresse à
François Bayrou et maintenant il va nous
dire comment faire voilà
c'est pas moi qui vais dire comment
faire je raconte seulement une histoire
j'avais avec François Mitterrand des
relations qui étaient humainement bonnes
même si politiquement nous étions
adversaires
et
un jour je le voyais
particulièrement sombre il y avait des
affaires qui traînaient
et je lui dis enfin je l'interroge sur
ça je ne sais pas quoi je dis une phrase
en disant mais l'État doit pouvoir et il
me dit il n'y a plus d'État
ah je dis pourquoi il y a plus il était
président de la République
et j'étais ministre du gouvernement il
n'y a plus d'État et je dis pourquoi
dites-vous qu'il n'y a plus de détails
il m'a dit parce qu'il n'y a plus de
raison d'État
la raison d'État vous savez c'est cette
exception qu'on fait à toute justice au
bénéfice de l'État c'est cette admirable
sauf conduit qui dans Les Trois
mousquetaires d'Alexandre Dumas
avait été remis
et dont les mousquetaires se sont servis
pour éliminer Milady il y avait écrit
c'est sur mon ordre et pour le bien de
l'État que le porteur du présent a fait
ce qu'il a fait
et la nostalgie de François Mitterrand
exprimer directement à quelqu'un pour
qui il avait
bienveillance et
c'était ça
pensait que la fin de la raison d’état
que les juges et les journalistes
pouvant
accéder ou chercher à accéder au secret
des tas supprimer l'État et bien nous
nous croyons exactement le contraire
oh nous ne croyons pas que la
transparence absolue existe
nous croyons pas du tout que il faille
allumer les projecteurs au dessus des
chambres à coucher des excellents sous
non mais nous pensons qu'il y a au fond
à
repousser
le cynisme de ceux qui pensent que la
fin justifie les moyens et nous nous
pensons qu'il y a une unité profonde
consubstantielle on dirait si on voulait
faire de la théologie une unité profonde
entre la fin et les moyens
et nous nous efforçons
d'en mettre là c'est la raison pour
laquelle cette famille politique
a pu depuis de longues années en tout
cas depuis que j'en ai la responsabilité
évitez d'être prise dans aucun scandale
aucun des scandales qui ont marqué
marquer les temps que nous vivons voilà
seul indication mais c'est à vous
maintenant la parole une seule règle
comme vous savez alternance féminine
masculin
féminin masculin féminine masculine si
il s'agit du qualificatif pour les
questions
attendez attendez il vous faut un micro
autrement vous ne serez pas enregistré
et pas entendu par internet alors qui
qui
distribue le micro il y avait David non
non il y avait
là franchement j'avoue que j'avais pas
réfléchi à cette question
pour la bonne raison que vous ne
l'ignorez pas notre histoire politique
et celle de la masculinité j'ai pas dit
de la virilité masculinité
ce qui est sûr en tout cas ceux qui
doivent faire l'objet me semble-t-il
d'une réflexion de du politique du
législateur c'est réfléchir précisément
sur ce l'un des points sur lesquels j'ai
insisté à savoir cette conception
régalienne est très propriétaire de des
élites politiques françaises et donc à
la nécessité éventuellement de mieux
répartir cette propriété c'est à dire de
mieux répartir les charges d'élus c'est
à dire éventuellement d'aller vers le
non cumul d'aller vers le
raccourcissement des mandats d'aller
vers une meilleure répartition
sociologique de cette des détenteurs du
pouvoir politique
ça avec aussi la lutte contre le conflit
d'intérêt mais c'est encore autre chose
maintenant dire qu'une femme a priori
est moins sensible aux sirènes de la
corruption qu'un homme j'aimerais le
croire mais j'avoue que là dessus je
n'ai pas de on pensait nos pensées
vraiment
alors
si l'on si l'on considère que les
moteurs les moteurs de la masculinité
sont effectivement l'argent le pouvoir
et le sexe m'envoie le mettre à part
éventuellement éventuellement parce que
je me permettrais pas une telle
assemblée on pourrait considérer que ce
goût de l'argent qui est qui fait partie
aussi peut-être qui fait partie
intégrante de cette conception du
pouvoir que ce que se fait le mal dans
une société démocratique peut-être qui a
quelque chose effectivement d'assez
masculin mais franchement là je je ne
suis pas qualifié je suis pas compétent
moi je peux pas parler d'honnêteté
personnelle en fait de l'argent je peux
parler d'un être intellectuel
moi je suis à des rares politiques
authentiquement féministes qu'on puisse
trouver non pas misogyne mais filogie il
suffit de regarder mes équipes pour se
faire une idée de de cette phylogie
parce que je pense en effet que
nombre de femmes sont engagées davantage
profondément dans les idées dans les
convictions dans l'attachement à un
courant politique
nombre mais pas toutes
parce que je peux citer je pourrais
citer sous la tortue mais je serais pas
torturé je pourrais citer de des
exceptions
notables mais pour l'essentiel en effet
peut-être en raison de cette
de cet aspect hormonal de coq qui veut
régner sur sur le tas de fumier dans sur
lequel il se trouve que les hommes
politiques ont assez souvent
en effet ils sont eux plus fragiles en
face de la tentation du pouvoir de plus
fragile mais il y a des exceptions je
voudrais citer une deuxième chose alors
qui est de l'ordre aussi de ce que j'ai
rencontré personnellement dans ma vie
j'ai vu de près le mécanisme qui se
produisait lorsque un certain nombre des
hommes politiques dont les
accidents ont été retentissants et
dévoilement de dérives ont été très
graves j'ai vu ce qui s'était passé un
certain nombre de cela dans les années
90 ont pensé
comparant la situation matérielle qui
était la leur qui leur était faite en
tant comme politique et la situation
matérielle qui leur était faite qui
était faite à l'heure
collègues a mis condisciple par exemple
de l'ENA les uns dans la fonction
publique les autres dans le monde du
privé
il disait mais enfin on n'est pas plus
mauvais que et on est même meilleur que
alors qu'est-ce qui justifie que eux ont
leur fasse des situations comme ça et
nous que nous soyons dans la difficulté
car je vais dire une phrase qui est
incompréhensible et qui serait pas
accepté par un très grand nombre de nos
concitoyens car
un homme politique honnête ne peut pas
s'enrichir par son mandat
il peut quelquefois
s'enrichir par d'autres voies
héritage
sa propre ses propres dons
d'entrepreneurs mais un homme politique
un parlementaire honnête
il a en raison de l'obligation des
obligations de sa charge et en raison du
fait qu'il a deux en général
localisation
cet homme politique
ce parlementaire là surtout s'il n'a que
ce mandat il ne peut pas
constituer un patrimoine comme on
l'entend dans ces milieux et donc j'ai
des noms extrêmement précis des visages
extrêmement précis devant les yeux
j'ai entendu leur récrimination
par exemple un parlementaire honnête il
peut pas aller dans un hôtel 5 étoiles
or il y a beaucoup de gens qui
considèrent que la vie
parce que leur copain de classe
ont ce genre de ville et les vacances
sont tueuses les hôtels somptueux ils
avaient un sentiment de déclassement
et leur faiblesse elle venait beaucoup
de ce sentiment de déclassement là alors
c'est quelque chose qui est
naturellement très difficilement
explicable parce qu'on dit quand on dit
ce qu'est le salaire d'un parlementaire
qui est de l'ordre de
4800 euros pendant les 25 premières
années de sa vie parlementaire pour le
pour le français salarié moyen c'est
évidemment beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
mais quand vous êtes cadre chez Renault
Peugeot de
chez Ariane espace ou dans le nucléaire
c'est une toute petite somme
et il y a cette parce que c'est vraiment
un temps de mutation
la mutation principale de notre temps
elle est dans le creusement des
inégalités
avec
95% de la population qui reste plutôt
dans le bas de l'échelle mais les 5% les
plus hauts et les 1% les plus hauts et
les uns pour 1000 les plus hauts et
quand vous êtes
sortis dans la botte de l'ENA vous
considérez que vous êtes plutôt dans le
un pour 1000 et bien là vous vous
trouvez
spectaculairement déclassé
c'est à dire que vous pouvez pas avoir
un appartement à Paris pour une famille
si vous n'en avez pas hérité alors c'est
des choses extrêmement difficiles à
expliquer parce que naturellement vous
voyez
quel crée une espèce de scandale
publique pour des gens qui vivent avec
1500 euros par mois
mais ça a joué un rôle très important
très important auprès de gens brillants
reconnus et qui tout d'un coup ce sont
laissés entraîner dans ces dérives là
voilà c'est des nuances mais je me
devais de le dire parce que
quelquefois il y a aussi des
explications sociologiques à des
faiblesses personnelles
d'abord vous n'avez pas respecté je vous
donne la parole après on va respecter
l'alternance
j'avais deux questions donc une première
à l'intervenant et ensuite une à
Monsieur Bayrou sur les dérives de
systémiques tout à fait d'accord avec le
terme que vous avez employé mais il y a
vraiment deux rouages essentiels et
fondamentaux dans ce dans cette dérive
systémique d'un côté les citoyens et de
l'autre les institutions et à propos des
citoyens je suis évidemment très
pessimiste
vis-à-vis de leur exigence comme vous
avez dit de de vérité et d'intégrité
vis-à-vis des élus alors deux exemples
pour pour argumenter c'est on peut citer
l'exemple de Nicolas Sarkozy qui au
lendemain de la mise en examen un
sondage qui a été effectué on arrive à
60% des Français qui estiment un retour
possible qu'il a encore un avenir
politique deuxième exemple dans
l'actualité c'est l'affaire Cahuzac avec
sa petite balade dans le marché et les
réactions des individus qui estiment
qu'il peut encore se présenter de
nouveau bon après il n'est pas encore
candidat on le verra bien et c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que comme vous
disait tout à l'heure le fait de tous
pourris finit banaliser finalement cette
corruption et du coup
finalement la proposition là que vous
disiez en citant l'exemple du système
norvégien ce système norvégien ça passe
par un vote qui doit passer par
l'Assemblée et j'en viens de maintenant
au deuxième point sur les institutions
et là encore tout à fait d'accord sur le
fait que vous ayez parlé de dons et de
contre don parce que c'est vrai que d'un
côté je l'ai partie majoritaire vu le
mode de scrutin ce sont eux qui votent
ces lois là qui les concernent eux-mêmes
puisque finalement ce sont les élus et
on voit bien que finalement les
propositions qui ont été faites ce sont
vraiment des propositions à minima parce
qu'il y a pas eu réellement de grands de
grands changements et voilà comment
régler ce problème là des institutions
qu'il faut qui font blocage pour une
avancée vers plus justement de
d'intégrité et j'en viens la deuxième
question du coup sur la moralisation
j'ai vu les propositions que vous avez
formulées et je voulais savoir en fait
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas allé jusqu'à
en fait l'inégibilité à vie et seulement
jusqu'à l'inégibilité de 10 ans
c'est très poser des questions très très
fondamentales
par quel par quel bout les prendre
d'abord juste deux secondes pour revenir
ce que disait François baillon parce que
pas très longtemps j'ai participé à une
émission de radio avec deux élus de la
République un droit une de gauche et il
me disait exactement ce que vous me
disiez c'est à dire que
écoutez nous on était on a choisi ce
métier alors nos motivations c'est le
service public c'est aussi une partie de
la gloire ils l'ont reconnu mais lui il
me disait moi si je retourne dans ma
société de conseil je vais gagner 10
fois plus et elle me disait moi si je
retourne je sais plus ce qu'elle était
avocat d'affaires je vais aussi gagner
10 fois plus donc il faut bien avoir ça
en tête pour pour comprendre et
comprendre aussi ce que ce qu'a
représenté ce qui est au fond une une
vertu historique de notre système
c'est-à-dire la
la promotion républicaine
devenir avoir un rôle politique ça fait
partie aussi de cette de cette promotion
de cette ascenseur social républicain et
il est normal aussi que ça amène à une
conception assez élitiste de l'exercice
du pouvoir et que cette conception
élitiste puisse entraîner aussi des
dérives dans la conception qu'on se fait
de l'usage de ce pouvoir mais je reviens
à votre à votre questionnement c'est
vrai que la banalisation ça c'est
quelque chose de très
historiquement très très daté enfin je
veux dire que c'est on le constate
depuis les années 80 tous les sondages
le montrent bon résignation sinisme
banalisation du scandale ce que ce que
montre aussi notre vie politique c'est
que la plupart des élus qui ont été
condamnés sont revenus dans dans la vie
politique est-ce que ça veut dire que la
société française de 2013 n'est pas plus
exigeante et ne demande pas plus de
transparence qu'elle n'en exigeait à la
fin du 19e siècle là en revanche je me
pose des questions et je pense de façon
optimiste que et qu'il y a un mouvement
qui relève de la maturation d'une
démocratie de l'ouverture de l'écoute de
ce qui se passe précisément dans les
autres pays européens ou aux États-Unis
et qui fait que à travers aussi la
multiplication des médias de la volonté
d'investigation des contre-pouvoirs
c'est là que c'est très très important
aussi que les contre-pouvoirs puissent
jouer leur rôle à plein et bien je pense
qu'il y a une aspiration une demande une
demande des citoyens pour plus de
transparence plus de moralisation en
tout cas parce que je répète le mot
transparence peut être ambigu et je
pense que ce en dépit ce que les
sondages peuvent vous dire et en dépit
de ce que les de ces résurrections
ponctuelles de telle ou tel homme
politique a tel moment discrédité au
fond fondamentalement il y a une
aspiration vers la vers la règle vers la
vers la normalisation vers la
moralisation je le pense merci je vous
réponds deux mots pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai écrit 10 ans au lieu de avis
pour deux raisons
l'une est juridique l'autre est
moral au philosophie cause spirituelle
celle qui est juridique c'est que cette
inconstitutionnel on peut pas faire une
peine à vie comme ça
la deuxième c'est que
j'appartiens courant de pensée de
conviction qui pense que les gens
peuvent toujours s'amander
même si
ou les deux mais enfin s'amender
et j'ai un argument complémentaire
c'est que quelques fois ça n'est pas ce
qui ont fait les choses les plus graves
qui se font choper
je pourrais citer largement
et donc
quelqu'un qui
se fait attraper et condamné il va être
privé 10 ans et l'autre dont je sais
qu'il a fait plus grave
bon alors ça me retient d'avoir cette
espèce de
d'intégrisme de voilà du doigt pointer
de l'accusé voilà j'ai pas envie d'être
le savonarol j'ai beaucoup porté les
thèmes de la moralisation et de et de et
du refus de la compromission avec tout
ça et je l'ai je crois pratiquer sans
doute vouloir me donner un exemple mais
voilà l'explication je vous ai livré
tous les secrets de la réflexion que
j'ai conduite parce que il aurait été
électoralement plus
favorable de dire de ce draper dans dans
la pureté et de dire à vie voilà
pourquoi je l'ai pas fait monsieur
voulait dire OUI OUI
pour prendre l'exemple de de l'affaire
Cahuzac ce qui compte pour nous ça n'est
distance qui va devenir de Monsieur
Cahuzac bon
on espère que en tout cas il va
comprendre à quel point il a joué un
rôle dans ce fossé qui s'est creusé avec
la classe politique mais ce qui compte
c'est la manière que la façon dont les
politiques vont mettre en place ou pas
des institutions des organismes de
régulation qui vont empêcher que ce qui
s'est passé se reproduisent on est
d'accord c'est ça qui est important me
semble-t-il bref merci vous vouliez dire
quelque chose c'était juste une
réflexion sur votre intervention
je vais vous demander pourquoi à votre
avis
les gens qui ayant fait ces études-là et
sachant ce que vous avez très bien
décrit ont plutôt choisi à la sortie de
la fin de leurs études et à la sortie de
l'école de faire de la politique plutôt
que de rentrer chez Renault chez Peugeot
ou chez Airbus mais vous y avez
parfaitement répondu je vais même aller
un peu plus loin
il y a des gens pour qui il y a des
choses qui comptent plus que l'argent
c'est à dire qui pense que alors je oh
je ne les classes pas du côté des anges
pures et radieux et je ne m'y classe pas
mais
moi je suis d'une génération
pour laquelle
les grands destins
c'était pas la banque
j'ai un jour c'était mon premier cette
sur 7 je vous parle d'un temps que les
voix de 20 ans ne peuvent pas connaître
j'étais très fier de faire cette sur
cette j'ai compris après coup que
j'étais détenteur d'un très gros marché
public puisque j'étais président d'une
très importante collectivités locales et
que Bouygues était candidat à ce très
gros marché public
mais je n'avais vu que du feu moi je
croyais que c'était pour mes dons qu'on
m'a invité à 7 sur 7
cette partie de l'interview sera coupée
il y a un montage et donc j'ai fait mais
ils ont pas eu le marché c'est je dis ça
pour que Oni soit qui malipense et donc
à mon premier 7 sur 7
j'ai été interrogé par Anne Sinclair à
l'époque qui m'a demandé pourquoi
j'avais choisi la politique j'ai dit
pour moi
les grands destins les vies qui valaient
la peine c'était ça c'était les grands
capitaines politiques les les grands
noms c'était Clémenceau c'était des gens
de cet ordre j'ai dit je ne pouvais pas
choisir d'être banquier parce que pour
moi banquier c'était le guichet du
Crédit Agricole Anaï le chef-lieu de
canton je vous jure je vous jure il m'a
fallu des des années d'adulte pour
comprendre que banquier voulait dire
autre chose d'âge presque adulte pour
pour comprendre que banquier voulait
j'ai reçu des lettres furieuses de mes
copains du Crédit Agricole
remise en quoi alors nous avons voilà et
donc et donc
il y a des gens qui qui croisent eux
allez disons la vérité la notoriété ou
le ou le succès ou la gloire ça compte
beaucoup ça comptait beaucoup pour pour
nous à l'époque
un jour un de mes amis à qui je voyais
un destin politique
est venu me voir et il partait dans le
privé et je lui dis mais pourquoi tu
pars avec avec ce que tu as
il m'a dit oui mais je veux me
constituer un patrimoine et il est
devenu un très grand capitaine
d'industrie c'est pas constitué un
patrimoine midi patrimoine
et bon mais pour répondre à une question
qu'on m'a posé là est-ce que vous
échangeriez la vie non je changerai pas
la vie c'est c'est
en quoi c'est aussi une vocation vous
comprenez
alors
elle n'a pas que la volonté de service
public comme ils disent au micro quand
ils sont devant le micro mais il y a
quelque chose d'autre d'une réalisation
personnelle voilà
Jean-Pierre Riou qui ne cette question
n'était qu'une remarque Jean-Pierre
Rioux voulait poser une question
d'abord pour acquis
pardon pour hacker ces personnellement
et à titre familiale avec ce que vient
de dire
François Bayrou sur le service de l'État
et l'accomplissement personnel qui peut
saisir un certain nombre de ces gens non
on a une question très compliquée à
gérer aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la
moralisation en cours parce que tout ce
qui choque moralement n'est pas
nécessairement illégal
et c'est ça nos problèmes
d'ajustement entre ce qu'est la légalité
et ce qu'est notre exigence morale ou
moralisante et donc moi je me pose la
question au fond de à quel étage
républicain c'est le plus facile d'être
ou non d'être corrompu parce que et là
on a peu de travaux historiques
finalement
parce que oui on comprend bien que dans
une culture de la raison d'État qu'on a
dit et qui est très française et qui est
pas du tout anglo-saxonne très bien on
comprendrait que au sommet de l'État
c'est soit peut-être plus tentant ou
voire plus facile mais ce que je vois
pas et ça c'est une question politique
qui nous intéresse ici tout
particulièrement comment ça se passe à
la base
comment ça se passe et là je pose la
question à tous ceux qui sont en train
de faire des listes municipales quelque
part comment il y a connaissance ou non
et pratique ou non en dehors je dirais
de la connaissance
approfondie des dossiers des dossiers
municipaux comment on repère ou non la
faille de démocratie de qui est à quel
étage selon toi il est plus facile
d'être corrompu voilà ma question
alors il s'agit pas de faire du cloche
merde mais il s'agit de ne pas toujours
je le répète je le répète le moi il me
semble que une des caractéristiques
français justement mais comme le montre
les enquêtes qui sont menées c'est
précisément que ce cette corruption des
élites n'est que la partie j'allais dire
émerger d'un iceberg qui recouvre
beaucoup de pratique qui ne touchent pas
d'ailleurs que le la classe politique
mais qui couche qui touche le monde des
entreprises le monde du sport
et donc les alors les études locales on
en a on en a très peu si ce n'est des
choses qui relèvent beaucoup de la
rumeur parce que ce sont des choses très
difficiles à trouver mais
évidemment que avec la notamment depuis
les lois de décentralisation sa se
multiplier les occasions de docorompre
ce sont multipliés et
je pense à au témoignage de Michel
Édouard Leclerc qui à propos des
implantations de d'hypermarché
dizaines manières très claire que elle
donnait lieu de manière systématique à
ce qu'on peut appeler de la corruption
voilà donc à partir de là effectivement
c'est peut-être encore plus facile à
l'échelle locale et d'ailleurs les les
grandes affaires de corruption des
années 90 ce sont partis de son ont été
découvertes d'abord à l'échelon local
avant de la ferrure basse est partie du
d'une enquête sur Montpellier sur les
municipalités donc voilà on est là en
présence d'un de quelque chose d'un
archipel bon de petites et de grandes
dérives de petits grands
dysfonctionnements
moi je pense que il y a une corruption
décentralisée
comme il y a pouvoir décentralisé il y a
une corruption décentralisée
et si on faisait la Somme
des montants en jeu je suis persuadés
que la corruption décentralisée
additionnait simplement par addition
représenterait plus
et donc voilà ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose il y a un élément
favorisant de la corruption
c'est l'hégémonie de deux parties à des
ternam sur la vie politique française
tant que vous avez
un mécanisme qui réserve le pouvoir
à la techno structure ou la
technopolitico structure de deux parties
hégémoniques assurées de conserver le
pouvoir ou de retrouver le pouvoir quand
ils l'ont perdu par un phénomène de
vases communicants vous avez
sédimentations des mœurs de corruption
passive et active parce que si vous êtes
le corrupteur il vous suffit de mettre
des billes sur les deux camps
et vous êtes sûr de gagner
et donc ne vous étonnez alors vous
mettrez des scénarios et des noms sur
tout ça mais moi je vous garantis que
c'est vrai
tant qu'il n'y aura pas plus réalise à
l'Assemblée nationale je répète que les
parties qui refusent de se soumettre
à la loi des deux hégémonies ont 40 plus
de 40% des voix au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et moins de 1%
des sièges à l'Assemblée nationale
le
Parti de Gauche de Mélenchon zérosiège
nous deux et le Front National 2 ça fait
4 sur 577 c'est donc
0,6 ou 7 % des sièges voilà point à la
ligne et donc vous voyez qu'il y a là un
phénomène de distorsion démocratique
sans avoir à juger des orientations des
uns et des autres qui est destructeur
pour la lutte contre ses habitudes là
parce que si vous avez toujours le même
personnel et assez souvent les mêmes
personnes et bien le
l'élan
démocratique d'envie de justice d'idéal
que vous représentez là ne peut pas
s'exprimer dans les institutions ça ne
durera pas je suis persuadé que tout ça
va trouver un jour ou l'autre une
réponse féminine
donc bonsoir
donc Monsieur Bayrou là vous évoquez le
rôle des centres finalement pour réguler
pas du tout j'évoque le rôle du
pluralisme d'accord est-ce qu'on peut
poser comme question le rôle des centres
pour réguler
au niveau de ma commune
frontenay-aux-roses 26000 habitants 92
Sud
aujourd'hui une liste
udi UMP et une liste MoDem
UMP donc des centres
dispersés et sans force
qui sera capable de ces propositions en
tant que rempart les centres ou les
populistes et question deuxième question
que pensez-vous en contre pouvoir
politique
d'un collège de dirigeants au niveau des
communes et d'un binôme homme-femme pour
la présidence de la République bon c'est
pas le sujet de notre soirée donc je
vais répondre très rapidement je connais
pas la situation de Fontenay-aux-Roses
par nature j'ai envie de vous dire
regardez la liste sur laquelle il y a
des modem c'est la meilleure mais mais
je n'ai pas examiné les choses
alors quand au truc binôme masculin
féminin franchement ça m'emballe pas
mais
je trouve pas ça convaincant mais cela
dit
je vais vous dire ça n'est accessoire
par rapport à l'incapacité où nous
sommes de réformer notre notre vie
politique locale on va garder des
régions des départements des métropoles
des communautés de communes des
communautés d'agglomération des communes
tout ça c'est incompréhensible par le
commun des mortels et en plus pour ces
fonctions là
notamment à cause d'élection de cet
ordre la plupart des élus sont
totalement inconnus un conseiller
général c'est connu à la campagne c'est
totalement inconnu en ville
il est élu simplement parce que le jour
du scrutin il a la bonne étiquette
mais des gens totalement inconnus
ignoré les conseillers régionaux dans
mon département je suis pourtant un
observateur assez attentif de la vie
politique il y en a 17 ou 18 je n'en
connais pas cinq
oui bon ben voilà pour les mers je
crois pas au collège alors là j'aurai un
avis qui va vous heurter
vous voulez maintenir toutes ces petites
je n'ai appris qu'une seule chose dans
enfin je n'ai changé que sur un point
dans ma vie entre le jeune garçon de 20
ans que j'étais et le garçon de 20 ans
un peu plus âgé que je suis aujourd'hui
il n'y a qu'une différence quand j'avais
20 ans ou 18 ans j'étais
auto-gestionnaire je croyais que les
communautés humaines pouvaient faire
surgir une volonté
et voilà et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'avais des cheveux très
très et aujourd'hui
je suis
de ceux qui pensent que le leadership
est en démocratie la chose la plus
importante
j'ai trouvé cette semaine une phrase de
Valérie qui est formidable il dit
s'il est un pouvoir réel
dans ce pouvoir il y a du moi
et bien la démocratie voilà pourquoi je
suis plus pour la Cinquième République
que pour la quatrième République
mais la sixième je sais pas ce que c'est
mais si la sixième c'est le retour à la
quatrième je suis contre
si la sixième c'est les avantages de la
cinquième avec une un pluralisme
organisé je suis pour mais ce que
veulent un certain nombre de défenseurs
guillemets de la sixième que j'ai été et
je me suis séparé d'eux sur ce point
c'est qu'il n'y ait plus d'autorité or
moi je suis pour qu'il y ait une
autorité
et c'est même le seul moyen de faire
bouger les choses voilà ce que je crois
mais c'était pas le sujet masculin et
puis féminin ultime
surpris de voir qu'il y avait très peu
de copropriétaires qui votaient pour le
compte séparé c'est-à-dire ce qui permet
vraiment un véritable contrôle des
comptes parce que évidemment on paye un
petit peu plus cher donc on fait une
petite économie et pourtant c'est
capital je peux vous attester qu'un
syndic de coffre-feuilleté peut se
remettre plein les poches sans que
personne y voit rien alors il suffit
avec le Parlement vote compte c'est
parure obligatoire et puis il y aurait
peut-être plus moyen de de détournement
à fond et puis peut-être qu'il y aura
plus de vocation je ne sais pas à
contrôler les comptes enfin j'ai
l'impression que c'est un exemple manger
j'ai vécu mais monsieur tibéry a été
condamné les électeurs de 5e ont réélu
je me dis mais il faudrait peut-être bon
je sais pas moi il y a quelque chose qui
déconne que voilà
non mais cet exemple prouve à quel point
pose la question de l'investissement
démocratique qui est fondamental pour
précisément le contrôle des élus mais
pour qu'il y ait cet investissement du
citoyen dans cette dans cette régulation
dans ce contrôle des élus il faut qu'il
soit motivé par la vie politique et
formé ça c'est fondamental que que
éduquer éduquer aussi à des valeurs je
pense que la question des valeurs aussi
la question de la de l'expertise aussi
mais voilà je sais même plus que oui
cette cette question là elle renvoie à
ce que disait François Bayrou
précisément sur cette bipolarité
hégémonique qui nous qui paralysent
totalement la vie politique en France
autour de la présidentialisation de
deuxième tour la présidentielle parce
qu'elle a tué le parlementarisme le
Parlement c'est une chambre
d'enregistrement et elle a tué les
parties les parties ne sont que des
machines enfin les deux grands partis ce
que les politologues britanniques
appellent les cartels les parties du
cartel ne sont que des machines à
fabriquer des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle et plus à produire de la
pensée à produire des idées et donc
paralysiste totalement tout ce qui est
la réforme en réalité on le verra bien
j'en fais le pari y compris sur ces lois
de moralisation proposées par par
François Hollande ande donc je reviens à
ça pour qu'il y ait investissement du
citoyen dans le contrôle des élus il
faut qu'ils soient formés qui soit
éduqués puis qu'il ait envie de le faire
et pour qu'il ait envie de le faire il
faut qu'il y ait une offre démocratique
pluraliste
un mot ça sera peut-être le mot de la
fin avant que je ne remercie Jean
garrigue quand j'étais jeune j'étais
très amie avec un homme politique qui
n'avait pas en eu encore le destin qui a
été le sien qui s'appelait Helmut cool
décidément j'ai l'impression de de
cultiver
les temps protos historiques et je
parlais beaucoup avec elmouth collé
notamment de la constitution allemande
qui dont vous aurez observé c'est quand
même très intéressant qu'elle n'a jamais
été changée depuis la guerre
depuis que depuis l'après-guerre nous
nous passons notre temps à changer la
constitution eux alors je parlais de ce
sujet avec lui un jour
il me disait tu sais
pourquoi nous avons des institutions qui
sont comme ça
inchangé ou protéger au travers du temps
c'est parce qu'on a tellement souffert
nos peuples allemands d'avoir des
institutions boiteuses ou bancales qu'on
a réfléchi pendant des années y compris
dans les milieux
anti-nazis pendant la guerre à ce que
pourrait être les institutions après et
on parlait du mode de scrutin et il m'a
dit et il y a au moins donc qui est très
intéressant
il m'a dit qu'il y a au moins une chose
qui est aussi importante que celle là
c'est qu'ils ont décidé de faire une
immense œuvre d'éducation civique par
les partis politiques
fondations les syndicats fondations et
les religions
sur il m'a dit c'est pour ça que sur la
feuille d'impôts des Allemands il y a
l'affectation à une religion à une autre
parce qu'on fait une sorte de service
public de la formation civique assurée
par les trois grandes institutions qui
organisent la société allemande et bien
j'ai souvent pensé que ce besoin
d'éducation civique là c'est une chose
absolument essentielle je vais en
ajouter une et ne crois pas ne croyez
pas que je sois un rat d'auteur plus
exactement je le suis mais un radiateur
qui considère que son radotage est fondé
et la chose qui manque le plus c'est le
calcul mental
les ordres de grandeur parce que les
gens ne comprennent pas ce que c'est
qu'un milliard
ce que c'est que
qu'est-ce qui est plus grand 130
euros ou 400 millions
pour beaucoup d'esprits ça se discute
l'affaire tapis n'aurait pas été
acceptée par la société française si les
gens avaient su ce que représente 400
millions d'euros
il aurait pas accepté mais 400 millions
d'euros ça passe vite ça passe aussi
vite que 400000 euros
un virement de 500.000 euros ça fait
beaucoup d'argent mais peut-être par
rapport à la circulation de somme que
par ailleurs en montant évoqué
c'est peu de choses mais vous voyez les
ordres de grandeur or ceci est de la
responsabilité de l'enseignement
primaire dans notre pays
j'ai essayé de le rétablir autrefois ça
a été effacé par mes successeurs mais
c'est très important on vient de
découvrir la étude d'avant-hier que la
France était le pays le plus en retard
pour les opérations arithmétiques
simples
et pourtant on a été très fort dans une
mathématique spéculative conceptuelle
très fort mais les opérations
arithmétiques qu'on faisait de tête
avec
les bûchettes pour savoir ce que c'était
des dizaines des centaines et des
milliers
ça a complètement disparu et c'est un
drame
civique je parle pas d'un drame
scientifique s'en est un j'avais essayé
avec Georges Charpak prix Nobel de
physique comme ministre de réintroduire
tout ça ça s'appelait La main à la pâte
ne réintroduire qu'est-ce que c'est ça
c'est 10 litres et combien ça représente
en centilitres et voilà
le cette idée-là de l'importance du réel
mesurable et des ordres de grandeur ça
serait une lutte contre la corruption
extrêmement précise le peuple français
n'aurait pas laissé s'endetter son pays
de 2000 milliards s'il avait su ce que
c'était 2000 milliards il aurait pas
fait
et donc vous voyez à quel point tout se
tient et je vous assure que je ne force
pas dans le sens de ce que je crois je
pense que c'est une c'est une discipline
physique que on ne devrait pas connaître
seulement du côté des directions des
services fiscaux
voilà en deux mots ce que je voulais
dire je voulais dire merci à Jean
garrigue pardon
Fadila dernière question
comme une volonté parallèlement
proportionnellement je dirais à créer
des boucs émissaires et qui eux du coup
reçoivent cette cette
question à la règle de façon extrêmement
délinquante
finalement un ciblage plus important sur
l'accuse d'être des racailles et c'est
tellement profond et c'est tellement
difficile cette demie c'est de de poids
de mesure
sur des modalités qui ne sont pas
toujours
la nôtre hier République
ça ça pose le la question de
l'exemplarité des élites et il est
évident que dans ce dans ce fossé social
qui se creuse est dans une période
particulière de de crise plus plus la
crise est forte et plus mal et ressenti
dans les catégories sociales les plus
défavorisées
cette impression au fond que voilà il y
a une sorte d'élite de l'argent comme ça
un petit peu mal identifié et qui qui en
prend à son aise avec avec
ces sommes là et c'est vrai que on
allait lui on peut avoir l'impression
que
la tolérance vis-à-vis de ces dérives là
elle est elle est contradictoire avec la
sévérité pour mais là encore moi je
pense qu'il faut être très prudent et je
la conclusion que j'en tire c'est un
devoir d'exemplarité de rigueur qui pas
de
la morale je sais pas bien ce que c'est
mais en tout cas d'exemplarité des
élites ça c'est sûr merci beaucoup agent
Gary